[Music]
first thing that comes to mind is very
few people can get into that kind of
shape you and I are probably the only
two on the planet where we're pretty
much the same bill same height you'll
have told you about six four in a little
bit maybe six six have I got stuff in
the hair all right
bit a little bit taller than I am okay
but you a man you got an amazing shape
for that and I'm just questioning first
of all no CGI there anything right
that's all you that's you yes okay me
what is in first of all that I find that
depressing I was hoping that was a
computer program yeah because then I
could tell my wife that can't be done
but yeah you got an amazing shape what
is what was required for you to do that
it was bet nine months of chicken breast
and broccoli and training training
weightlifting and yeah so just training
constantly eating just chicken breast
broccoli and that is it yeah no I mean
we had a really good chef who tried he's
who's a real artist and he really tried
to make it interesting and with herbs
and lemon juice no it doesn't like what
he the thing is his hands were tired cuz
he couldn't use cream you couldn't use
any sugar right none of that no like
fast cars no pasta no bread I can't and
is when a healthy chef says you know
look it's kind of like a pizza except
there's no bread or cheese or tomato
broccoli so for him was he's not really
a healthy chef he's just beats an artist
he loved I cook but the my trainer was
like well you can't use this you can't
use that you can't use so it was quite
tough for him okay
did you start to psychologically lose it
I would think I mean for how long had
you all because yeah it was I they gave
me six meals a day which is quite a lot
but the size of the portion was like
this size yeah so I was constantly
hungry and I have either eat every three
hours which meant that I spent the
entire day thinking about food yeah so
when I finished a meal I would go
alright 2 hours and 55 minutes of my
next video yeah and then like the entire
day would revolve around those meals and
I would just look forward to them and
we're talking a period of weeks
are we talking how long did this have to
go on for on
nine months nine months no I would
rather dig it right and then we wrapped
the movie here half the movie and I fell
off the wagon completely and five months
later David baron our producer called me
and said on so we have this little scene
we've added in the end of the movie that
we want to shoot in four months it's
about a five-second scene so can you go
back on that diet for that scene so
what'd you do that well in hindsight I
should have because you saw the mangani
the the ape there on that fella is cgi
so I thought I went back on the diet and
did another say CGI mf'er yeah if they
CGI the elephant's the Lions the Madani
come on another word for you body double
you know I would get a body double slap
a wig on him shoot him from another
angle and you're in the corner eating
haagen-dazs with a spoon Buddha good
that's why I would so would you be
interested in doing that for me if we
ever get to do another one I'll be your
body double anytime I gotta love that
scene in Tarzan where suddenly he hits
you and then suddenly Tarzan walks into
a room and his body is like I've
actually already cold and gross no but I
pitched that idea to Warner Brothers I
said if if we make another one because
our this the legend of tarzan begins ten
years after he left the jungle yes so it
opens in London he's there with Jane
yeah and then he returns to the jungle
and so what I figured well if we make
another one it could be ten years after
we finish this so maybe he's out of
shape
that's a no gamma yeah entire movie yeah
and it's overweighted dreams pina colada
yeah I love it I love it the Apes are
out of shape too it's just you in the
ape sitting around doing eating cheese
popcorn watching yeah picking lice off
each other that's a great idea for a
movie I would be a buddy go see that one
yeah
[Applause]
you